مجلس النواب الامريكيه يسيطر او يسطر
مذكره استدعاء بحق وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن ويمهله اسبوع فقط
للكشف عن وثائق تتعلق بفوضى الانسحاب من
افغانستان في اغسطس من عام 2021 مذكره
الاستدعاء بحقد لينكن تم توقيعها من قبل
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس النواب
الامريكي مايكل ماكو الذي كشف ان وزير
الخارجيه رفض تقديم برقيه وردع على
البرقيه ورد على البرقيه دفعه الى اصدار
اول مذكره استدعاء بصفته رئيس اللجنه
النائب الجمهوري كان قد اطلق تحقيقا بشان
الانسحاب الفوضوي للقوات الامريكيه من
افغانستان في عهد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن والاحداث التي شهدتها البلاد طبعا
منذ ذلك الحين وردا على هذه المذكره وعلى
مذكره الاستدعاء قالت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه لانها مستعده لاتاحه المعلومات
ذات الصله في البرقيه عبر افادات او اليات
اخرى وكان طبعا في وقت سابق اكدت انها
كشفت بالفعل عن المعلومات وتعمل على تقديم
المزيد لكن لا يمكن الكشف عن بعض التفاصيل
الدقيقه الا لمسؤولين كبار في خطوه تهدف
طبعا كما نعلم لحمايه هويه من عبروا عن
عبروا عن معارضتهم لهذا الموضوع بعض
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين يرون انه لا
توجد روايه كامله عن العمليه الفوضويه
لانسحاب القوات الامريكيه من افغانستان
والتي ذهب ضحايتها عينها ثلاثه عشر جنديا
امريكيا تحديدا في مطار كابل صحيفه كانت
نشرت تحقيقا تحدث عن ان اكثر من 20
دبلوماسيا امريكيا في افغانستان ارسلوا
برقيه سريه عبر احدى القنوات لتحذير بلنكن
في عام 2021
وتحديدا في يوليو من احتمال سقوط كابول في
ايدي حركه طالبان مع انسحاب طبعا القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد والذي وصف بالفوضوي
[موسيقى]